you're looking young there man have you
been using like a
do you use a toner or anything like that
like a facial toner
no no not at all not at all
you know when i was young we used to
we used to my dad would take us over to
the funeral parlor
and um and
you know we would do like uh
you know and it was sad and everything
but on top of that we would do a have a
candy or something try to hide a candy
in the coffin of whoever was
you know being buried or being
you know deceased whoever was deceased
or being buried if
and a lot of back then i mean something
sometimes probably three or four percent
of the people you don't know if they
were fully dead or not
you know you kind of trusted people's
family back then they said hey they're
dead you know come on over and
you know we're gonna box them up for god
you know
kind of deal but um
and we would try to sneak a candy in the
into the casket
you know try to slip a gum drop in there
or slip a uh
gob stopper in there um
because i guess the way we envisioned it
is you you would see you would think
you know then later on you know a week
later you'd be
just by yourself relaxing or
you know spending time with an animal or
something just
you know we're looking around or just
doing anything
and you would think oh that god got this
person
and then he found the candy in there
like a like a little treat
you know like a snack or something like
that you know
i think we used to envision god kind of
opening up the coffin and getting that
little snack being like oh yeah here's
one of my soldiers but also
you know here's half a handful of good
and plenty
that somebody snuck in there um
just different times you know uh
but i know you're a man of the cloth
riley now you ever do any time capsuling
any dead body time capsule or anything
like that for god you guys do any
stuff like that um not that i think uh
not that i can think of no
can't say you ever sinned like you guys
do a time capsule for
christ or anything like that through
church you guys do a
you know send a rocket up to god or
anything was there any fun stuff like
that you did as
children um not not for uh religious
purposes but i mean i've done time
capsules i've done
rockets um my dad's a rocket engineer
oh dang yeah yeah um
have you ever done it forgot you guys
ever built something for the lord and
just jacked that thing up into the sky
no i can't say i have not for the lord
i've just done it for fun
damn damn you living man
you're living big riley mal yeah man
it's the big time
let's get into it
[Music]
good evening good afternoon and other
times
thanks for watching that video you just
saw i mean it was okay
but the next video you can watch could
be way better what if you watch a video
right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one
watch this one watch this one watch this
one
ah